[Musique]
il ya quelques temps j'ai reçu un appel
téléphonique d'une amie un appel qui m'a
surprise un petit peu pour vous mettre
dans le contexte c'est une amie qui
vient d'afrique de l'ouest
elle a fait ses études supérieures ici
au canada je le considère très
intelligente et une amie vraiment
profonde d'une amie à laquelle je tiens
beaucoup et en qui je crois beaucoup
elle me faisait part d'une difficulté
personnelle qu'elle vivait en d4
j'arrive pas à trouver d'emploi je
cherche les gens ne me
veulent pas me recevoir en entrevue a
dit stop aux idées à quel point c'est
difficile pour une immigrante de
travailler ici au canada
et puis c'est une chose à laquelle je
n'avais jamais pensé mon en tant que tel
en général nos vies suivent un parcours
assez linéaire en est enfin on étudie
ont choisi une carrière on l'étudié et
puis on travaille plus on se pose pas
vraiment plus de questions que ça dans
la vie à la limite on va peut-être
changer de travail un jour puisque c'est
à peu près tout pour ma part mon
cheminement était un petit peu différent
motion personnes transgenres ce qui veut
dire qu'en fait j'ai dû faire beaucoup
d'efforts des efforts conscients et des
efforts assez soutenue pour pouvoir me
présenter devant vous aujourd'hui dans
cette danse est apparent cela pour
pouvoir me présenter dans une apparence
qui reflète mon identité profonde
on appelle ça une transition parce que
c'est évidemment un moment dans la vie
où on fait ça ma transition actuellement
est derrière moi ma transition pour ma
part c'est très bien passé c'est pas
tout le monde que cette chance là il ya
des gens qu'ils vivent différemment plus
difficilement
pour ma part j'ai eu énormément de
soutien de la part de ma famille de la
part de mes amis ç'a très bien été une
des chances que j'ai eus je n'ai pas
vraiment perçu comme une chance à
l'époque ça a été la chance de perdre
mon emploi
oui c'est vraiment merveilleux comme que
comme expérience de vie d'être à la fin
en période de transition de genre de
changer son apparence aussi
fondamentalement ce qui à la fin à une
période de recherche d'emploi c'est un
beau défi
puis je vous dirais que dans une
situation comme celle là on prend la
mesure du nombre de portes qui peut se
refermer devant nous un c'est pas mal de
portes dans la ville qu'on peut recevoir
dans la face pour vous mettre en
situation puis je vous promets j'ai
vraiment pas d'autres chefs après le
succès de l'ofppt c'est fini selon une
étude qui a été réalisée en ontario il
ya quelques années
39% des personnes qui se définissent
comme trans estime avoir déjà s'être
déjà vu refuser un emploi
je me sens en relation avec la situation
que vit mon ami qui vient d'afrique de
l'ouest
les personnes le taux de chômage chez
les personnes immigrantes ici au québec
est de 32 pour cent plus élevé que chez
les personnes qui
on est au québec ou au canada c'est une
difficulté qui peut être vécu de
différentes manières comment ce qu'on
vit ce souvent ça peut être quelque
chose comme des choses très très
subjective par exemple ben on n'a pas au
niveau de l'entrevue c'est le moment
idéal on n'a pas trouvé que tu match est
vraiment avec ce qu'on cherchait
exactement comme comme type de
personnalité que l'on voit pop du capot
tout est fait dans l'équipe son l'entend
beaucoup c'est des choses qui sont
subjectives c'est important pour moi de
le nommer parce que la subjectivité a
suivi dans les deux sens
je veux reconnaître le fait que quand on
[Musique]
quand on se retrouve dans une situation
comme celle là vous voyez à quel point
c'est difficile d'y repenser c'était
émouvant quand on se retrouve dans une
situation comme celle-là on apporte une
partie de notre insécurité avec nous et
la difficulté de se vendre en entrevue
vient comme confirmé la difficulté de la
personne ne nous accueillir ça reste
subjectif puis ça nous bloque mais ça
vient de nous finalement la base il ya
aussi d'autres situations qui sont
beaucoup plus objective comme par
exemple la difficulté de faire
reconnaître un diplôme ou encore une
expérience de travail qu'on a acquise
dans un autre travail dans un autre pays
comme dans le cas de mon ami d'afrique
de l'ouest ou qu'on a acquise sous un
autre nom
quand on peut pas vérifier une
information soit par la langue soit à
cause du non qui ait changé comme dans
une situation comme la mienne mais c'est
difficile de se faire valoir évidemment
pleinement les gens qui ont vécu un
cheminement comme le mien comme les gens
qui ont choisi de venir habiter ici on
partage quelque chose c'est quelque
chose d'important c'est l'importance et
la volonté de se redéfinir d'exprimer le
meilleur de nous même d'exprimer notre
identité profonde à la société et ça ça
passe énormément par le travail pourquoi
tout simplement parce que c'est au
niveau du travail que de manière
générale on contribue le plus à la
société c'est d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on
se fait payer parce qu'on contribue
quelque chose pour sur les salaires en
échange
pardon quand tu es quand on veut quand
on veut offrir le meilleur de nous même
quand on est confronté à une porte qui
se referme
comment est-ce qu'on peut réagir on a
fondamentalement trois manières de
réagir à une situation comme seule la
première ça peut être de tout simplement
accepter la situation et ne rien faire
on appelle ça se résigner maman à une
belle expression pour une situation
comme celle-là elle dirait de voulu être
une fille rendue au resto une belle
manière coloris bleu div
ça peut fonctionner une autre attitude
ça va être tout simplement de verbaliser
notre difficulté mais quand on reste
n'est pas à l'étape de verbaliser on
appelle ça se plaindre et puis ça aide
pas à avancer dans la vie la 3e étape
s'est passé à l'action passe à l'action
on appelle ça dans la vie de john des
citrons feu la limonade
avez vous déjà pensé à la recette parce
que c'est ça sonne facile quand on le
dit comme ça un mail cité des citrons
fait de la limonade si vous avez déjà
essayé comme moi de faire de la limonade
juste avec des citrons odopod 5 pas de
recette proportions c'est pas idéal
et puis c'est un petit peu seul avis
c'est que ça se réduit pas à une
situation aussi simple que celle là
parce qu'on veut exprimer quelque chose
de complexe g à la maison un livre qui
s'appelle le guide pratique un jeu qu'on
livre le guide pratique de l'innovation
jamais ouvert je le trouve fascinant en
fait je vous fais la version longue
je trouve facilement sans l'avoir ouvert
qui la version longue à vaut la peine
c'est en me l'a offert c'est mon prof à
l'université qui me le donnait 8 même on
le lui avait offert en cadeau est
lui-même le jamais offert soit le livre
aux quelque chose comme une malédiction
ou quelque chose comme ça y est condamné
pour toute sa durée de vie à être offert
plus jamais ouvert jamais lu par
personne soyez là quelque chose
d'important nous à nous annoncer à nous
à nous enseigner juste par sa propre
présence ce guide pratique un guide
pratique d'habitude c'est rapide et
efficace il fait 630 pas
ça nous exprime quelque chose à propos
de la complexité
on est beaucoup dans la mode des
recettes des guides pratiques des choses
faciles à suivre
des méthodes qui suffit de suivre pour
pouvoir s'exprimer pour pouvoir faire
n'importe quoi en font les out ou mais
il ya des situations qui se décrivent
comme ça puisse aider situation
fondamentale parce que tout le monde
mérite d'offrir le meilleur de soi même
même si on n'a pas fini son secondaire
même si on n'a pas d'expérience de
travail qui méritent d'être mises de
l'avant dans un cv même si on est au
travail depuis tellement longtemps
on n'arrive plus à sortir de notre zone
de confort
on a quand même on a tous quelque chose
de fondamental et d'importants exprimé
qui est notre identité profonde comme
mir et tous de trouver notre place dans
la société et de l'exprimer
ça se passe plus souvent qu'autrement à
travers le travail et c'est quelque
chose on s'est mis à y réfléchir avec la
compagnie que j'ai fondée on s'est
demandé comment est-ce qu'on pourrait
aider les gens a finalement trouvé leurs
recettes de comment s'exprimer en
sachant que c'est quelque chose de
tellement fondamentale que la recette
sera pas facile la solution qu'on a
trouvé ça a été de développer des
ateliers on a formulé des ateliers
participatifs où on utilise beaucoup le
co développement
ils les ateliers qu'on a inventé ce
fonds en trois séances la première
séance et qui suis-je où on part
vraiment mes rêves ce que je veux
réaliser dans la vie la deuxième séance
et mes outils d'information mon
expérience etc
puis la troisième séance s'appelle
littéralement mon plan d'action parce
que ce qu'on veut faire évidemment ce
pouvoir s'exprimer à travers à travers
qui on est notre expérience personnelle
et professionnelle dans la société
on utilise les outils qui ont été
formulées pour les entreprises des
outils comme l'analyse des forces et
faiblesses l'intelligence émotionnelle
porfolio de compétences le marché cible
est la valeur ajoutée
pourquoi on utilise les outils comme
cela parce que ça crée une distance une
objectivité qui permet à la personne de
se mettre en mode d'observation puis
d'avancer vers le développement son
propre son propre
le plan d'action et on travaille à
travers tous ceux des compétences
transversales comme valoriser mes
compétences mes valeurs qu est ce que je
suis comme personne et mon projet
personnel qu'est ce que je veux vraiment
exprimé dans la société
si chaque personne a le droit d'exprimer
fondamentalement son identité profonde
et à travers son travail de se
développer comme personne de la même
manière la société a le droit émérite
aussi de recevoir toutes ces expressions
individuelles
parce que c'est une personne à la fois
en exprimant son plein potentiel et un
croissant en se développant comme
personne qu'on contribue au progrès de
la société
aujourd'hui je suis très fier du travail
qu'on a accompli avec nos ateliers
on c'est magnifique de voir la réaction
des gens des participants dd des moments
qui sont des finissants des moments
vraiment de prise de conscience
ils sont très très beau avant moi
j'estime avoir trouvé ma voie à travers
le projet quelques sont ces ateliers là
et j'en suis très très fier je vous
invite aujourd'hui à réfléchir à votre
propre recette à vous demander ce que
vous exprimez à la société c'est
vraiment votre identité profonde
est ce que vous avez vraiment de plus
fondamental à offrir au monde
quant à mon ami qui vient d'afrique de
l'ouest mais je suis très heureuse de
dire qu'elle a déménagé au canada
anglais il ya quelques mois et qu'elle
travaille maintenant dans le domaine de
l'enseignement elle est super heureuse
très fiable du travail qu'elle accomplit
au quotidien une histoire qui finit bien
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]